there's two kinds of ideal sources we're
going to talk about one is an ideal
voltage source and the other is an ideal
current source
a ideal voltage source the symbol is
looks like
a circle
like that
we put a voltage indication right inside
there
and that's called v and this is a
constant voltage
what i've shown here is a
and that can come from a power supply or
it can come from a battery when it comes
from a battery we have a special symbol
for that the battery symbol looks like
this
and the convention for this we also
label it v
the convention for the polarity of a
battery symbol is the long
line there is the plus terminal and the
short line right there that guy is the
minus terminal
so that's the convention for a battery
the other type of ideal source is called
the current source
and it also has a symbol like with a
circle and this one we put an arrow and
it goes in the direction
of the current the current symbol is i
it can look like that or we could point
the arrow the other way like that
depending on how the application goes
and that's an ideal current source
and those are the two symbols for
constant
current
now one of the things we can do is we
can plot these we can plot these
uh two voltage sources the voltage
source and the current source we can
plot them on a curve that has
coordinates voltage
and current so this would be called an
iv curve or an iv plot that we're about
to do here
for a constant voltage source the
voltage doesn't change the current goes
up and down depending on what the rest
of the circuit demands
but the current the voltage is the same
everywhere so it plots something like
this
that would be the plot the iv plot of a
constant voltage where v equals some
constant v
and if we want to plot our constant
current source on this kind of iv plot
this would be something where the
current is always the same the current
is the same independent of the voltage
and so a plot of that for a positive
current
would look like this and we would say
something like i
equals a constant i
so that's the iv plot of a current
source and the iv plot
of a voltage source
all right these are the two basic ways
we deliver power or signals into
circuits
now we have a complete set of elements
that we can build things with